this hello welcome back to game starts
coverage of e3 2015 I've spent most of
the past three days sitting on my ass
watching everyone else enjoy it I'm a
boy youtuber champchong right here good
to meet you finally Daniel hey Dylan
buddy hey you guys have been out in a
bed actually enjoying the wonderful
where's that exist in the West Hollen
southall and I just heard that you were
playing battlefront like just now yeah
we finished like half an hour ago we had
about 20 minutes on the game and it was
amazing right oh yes much thought get
him up there where we're we're not kind
of funding all the fun they're too loud
I'll be super lag okay so you played
battle for like 30 minutes yeah
something like that yeah we had a match
and I got into the 8080 and I was just
like firing down and everyone is amazing
that's mental wait you shake it a dining
up definitely the best of the show yeah
it's you guys battle feel fans at all
yeah but mom I like the Star Wars aspect
that's interesting it's like definitely
coming from the other side cuz I'm like
a big for whatever reason I'm not a
massive star wars from but it's all
about 15 a mile of like battlefield 3
and 4 and does it feel like a game
that's like Star Wars fans would like I
always felt like battlefield was just
something like something was missing but
now it feels like this is battlefield
and star wars have somehow meshed
they've like that yeah it's like a bit
Lykke a nose like from the experience
and it's just something that they've
actually just made epic now so yeah it's
definitely feels like Star Wars so you
got an 80 80 what were you doing while
he was walking around in an 80 80 in
battlefront I was just getting shot
though so terrible and look at it's a
gay play over here it looks fantastic on
the gameplay we saw when you were
playing it was it running that well yeah
I noticed a few little bugs here and
there obviously it's a very early build
or it's not finished but yeah it was
really smooth like this right here in
the trenches and you can just pop out
every now and then you use like the
jetpack and just destroy people with
even the grenade launchers so much fun
I'm wizard was it like this was there
all like stuff flying through the air
and yeah I was in an imperial
excellent smart rocket man there's
something about all the gameplay demo as
we see I just wish that I had time to
actually get hands-on with all of them
and what else did you guys play today
what else is what we doing before
Battlefront well for me one game but I
think it's a play it was more like a
really cool experience was I got to use
the what do you call the Holy Land oh
yeah yeah I got got in here real early
before 8am and it wasn't really like a
hands-on you don't really move anything
but it's more just an experience was
this that the halo thing that they do
you like walk through like a halo set
that's great because we've heard from
everyone here that that's like got the
longest line in both conferences yeah so
did you have an exhibitor badge yeah get
in nice and that's the way to do it you
gotta pick one line though so that was a
good call what was it like you see like
a waypoint in the distance yeah it's
like a waypoint you know like mass
effect for example but a bit more simple
than that it's just like telling you
what it go and then you turn into this
like whole way yeah it's great off a
halo fan yeah yeah more of a call judy
family yeah fair enough and what about
stuff did you get to go with the
hololens thought I wouldn't let me hear
what led you a simulation carefully what
did you what did what else did you see
today we checked out Batman so much does
yeah there's like so many games run off
like three out of sleep okay did you
watch the conference's earlier in the
week uh yes sorry what was your favorite
out of the the microsoft sony and and I
guess nintendo is kind of a weird one
but but best yeah it's good answer I'm
right there we I spent aha I went on
Amazon straight away and spent like 130
bucks on this world's stupidest looking
on Apple watch and are you both for low
fans yeah oh yeah also tune they got the
creative map thing yeah map snap map
yeah yeah did you get a chance to see
doom at all I know but they're hardly
showing fall night I think only judges
week people are getting to see it and
did you like the demo up to my wasn't so
sure about it yeah when I first saw it I
was kind of unsure about it I was like
it looks like old doom but kind of
generic now but then they stood that
snap man
and I guess just it's doom and there's
just cool new features I'm excited to
see what they bring eventually hopefully
the one thing I was worried about was
that the speed didn't seem as fast as
how you play doom but you can never tell
at e3 because they sometimes show stuff
off a little bit slower so to make sure
you know if you're playing like dooming
just like darting all over the place and
mind it's old so i guess i'll have to
wait to get my hands on and you're
obviously a massive of knowledge well
when it comes to fifa you got loads of
videos online about it we had Nick
Cannon obviously I saw I think you
interviewed him as well I'm a couple of
days ago with his booth and he was
showing off FIFA we didn't get a
gameplay demo but we got we got some of
the like videos of how it looked you got
hands-on with it right yeah so what do
you think about this year's FIFA it
plays a lot slower but that's a good
thing because previously you could just
like split through the defense wouldn't
really do anything especially the
midfield was really weak and there was
spacing a game of attack now it's built
more through the midfield and I like
that and then obviously shootings been
improved it's going back to like fifa 14
but that often the screams of 15
shooting I found wasn't all that great
it was kind of like floating but it's
definitely improved excellence I know I
know when night ever sub playpens this
year but apparently that one's looking
pretty good as well so might be another
two year at a football game or soccer
games depending on where you are okay
football right work we're boat Islanders
other side of the world but it's
football and last thing you got to pick
anything out anything else you want to
see before the show closes in two hours
Daniel anything I wanted to say small
stuff but yeah they're sort of pretty
hush and all that up you know this hell
out there so I think I pretty much seen
everything excellent everything good
you've enjoyed your 3 i'm gonna make You
Chuck Chong you got anything else you
want to know I want to revisit something
have already visited and it's 35 to 50
really is he beat me on it I want to get
him back yeah excellent gentlemen thank
you so much for coming on and really
appreciate it especially you know you're
like it's sort of like by extension me
being to vicariously enjoy III through
you so I really appreciate it enjoy the
last two hours yeah of the conference
and thank you for watching on gamespot
and on YouTube and of course on hitbox
is I'll be back in just a minute with
more video games right before the show
wraps up stay there